ou les title Tuesday
chess.com/events Courouvre tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base retrouver
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contrerendus
quotidiens les bios des joueurs les
règles des partartag et plus encore vous
pouvez même participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats pour
tenter de gagner des abonnements premium
alors rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle par
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors les amis ça va bientôt
commencer je suis en train de de voir un
peu la la mise en place et de la
terminer pour qu'on ait bien les caméras
comme il
faut alors alirea hop la caméra on va la
mettre bien comme il
faut voilà et la caméra de Magnus
maintenant on va la mettre bien comme il
faut
aussi voilà les joueurs les joueurs qui
sont là
et donc cette finale qui va bientôt
commencer donc je vous rappelle c'est
une finale en quatre parties 10+ 2 au
meilleur des des quatre parties et et si
ala gagne il devra gagner un deuxième
match en deux parties gagnantes pourquoi
cette règle un petit peu particulière
c'est parce que alier Reza n'a plus
qu'une vie dans le tournoi et comme vous
le savez peut-être si vous suivez le
tournoi depuis le début c'est un tournoi
à double élimination et donc et donc les
les les les
joueurs
on devis et Magnus encore ses devis
alors qu'ala n'en a plus qu'une donc il
faudra qu'aliera
gagne de matchs coup sur coup contre
Magnus Carlsen mais il y en a un qui a
réussi à faire cet exploit majuscule il
y a pas si longtemps de ça le dernier en
date c'est un certain Maxime vach grave
son compatriote qui avait battu Magnus
Carlsen deux fois coup sur coup on va
voir si on peut réaliser cet exploit une
nouvelle fois côté côté
je pense que le match va bientôt
commencer je vois que les joueurs sont
en train de de
s'installer on voit
Magnus avec une coupe de cheveux
magnifique il graifie d'une superbe
coupe de cheveux
Magnus
et donc je pense sont tous les deux à
l'hôtel déjà pour le tournoi de 960 qui
commence
aprèsdain il sont pas dans les mêm
conditions ils auraient carrément pu
jouer là en face de l'autre je
crois à moins qu'il voyage demain en
tout cas ils ont pas l'air d'être au
même endroit ils ont dû voyager hier en
fait on va on va essayer de ne pas rater
la la
partie grande finale les chqu ça doit
bien être
celui-là c'est Magnus normalement qui va
commencer avec les pièces
blanches ça commence généralement à
écart en fait ces
matchs tout cas ces deux hommes sont
déjà qualifiés he pour le la prochaine
étape le vainqueur du tournoi sera aussi
qualifié au passage pour la grande
finale
et ça va commencer très très très
bientôt les joueurs qui sont concentrés
Magnus qui se lève là c'est vraiment les
derniers préparatifs à mon
avis dans moins de de 3 minutes on est
lancé à mon avis dans moins de 3 minutes
on est
lancé Magnus qui va qui va un peu
cherchailler encore
derrière qui va chercher deux trois
trucs
derrière je pense que quand Magnus
revient ce sera
lancé
qui est assez tranquille de toute façon
il a déjà réussi son tournoi il a pas la
la pression entre guillemets c'est quoi
qu'il en soit un exploit de Bat Magnus
deux fois donc il a pas ils sont super
per il pourra pas s'en vouloir serait
pas la même situation s'il avait
vraiment les les deux vies encore et
Magnus qu'une seule il aurait lui aussi
la pression mais là en ayant qu'une
seule vie contre deux c'est très très
dur est quand même arrivé jusqu'en
finale pour la prochaine étape il prend
une très grosse option sur la
qualification pour pour les finales qui
je crois sont à Toronto une nouvelle
fois mais ça j'en suis pas sûr à
vérifier donc aliera son tournoi il est
tout
bnef même s'il venait à perdre il y
aurait pas de déception
démesuré env qui m'emplace peut-être oui
sa deuxième caméra Magnus et ça y est
c'est parti ça part ça part à
17h15 et Magnus qui ouvre par G3 donc un
coup qui est très flexible mais il peut
vouloir potentiellement retomber Magnus
dans dans une catalane il y aura pas de
catalane qui joue alors ça peut
transposer dans des grunf on a vu
beaucoup Maxime notamment dans les title
Tuesday arriver dans dans ce genre de
position va voir ce qu' vaen être
aujourd'hui F G7 D4 cavalier F6 mais C4
C6 la grande position ah ben c on l'a
déjà vu des centaines de fois alors
après C6 c'est pas le seul coup et rock
rock et sur cavalier5 on a le fameux
cavalier G4 petite pensée à Fab qui aime
bien nous nous rappeler
cela al Reza qui
réfléchit bon c'est sûr qu'il connaît he
là c'est il a eu cette position des
centaines de fois il joue C6
prend son temps petit qui va jouer petit
rock et là Magnus a multiple choix peut
prendre en D5 on peut jouer cavalier C3
on peut jouer cavalier
E5 joue cavalier C3 DC4 et B5 il aime
bien Magnus donner ce pion en C4 pour se
conférer le le contrôle du centre et ala
donc qui joue B5 il conserve le pion a 5
peut avoir l'idée de jouer B4 x 6
C3 tour D1 peut-être cavalier
BD7 et sur5 cavalier
D5 le 5 des 5 que 6 ça se regarde mais
je pense pas que ça
passe on doit tous rentrer dans notre
partie moi aussi je dois rentrer dans ce
match dans cette finale et il joue des5
alors je pense qu'il connaît
encore et puis on prend E5 a plus
logique comme ça il va pouvoir prendre
en D5 après ici la théorie apparemment
c'est B4 c'était le seul coup prise F6
prise F6 cavalier B5 et E6 et on a
instantanément une position hyper
intéressante c fou D7 attaque le
cavalier au passage et on va voir le
pion à mon avis arrivé en E6 et position
hyper intéressante he les blancs qui ont
une pièce de plus mais en contrepartie
les Noirs ont trois pions et je pense
que les deux joueurs savent réellement
ce qu'ils font encore
maintenant donc là ça doit être 6 6 ça
donne vraiment envie parce que ça permet
de de
stabiliser toute la
structure et c'est une
position extrêmement complexe alors moi
je va vous dire que je prendrai plutôt
les Noirs quand même je trouve que c'est
plus facile de jouer avec les pions
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup ils sont au
nombre de trois et comme vous les voyez
matérialisés en rouge ils font
peur et ce pion B5 il est quand même
relativement VUL
vérable après pas de panique pour les
supporters de de Magnus hein vous voyez
la jauge qui montre quand même
toujours quelque chose proche de
l'égalité après de toute façon c'est du
connu hein il est rentré là-dedans de
guê de peur de guê de
cœur donc c'est qui sait ce qu'il fait
je commence à comprendre un problème par
exemple si on met la dame en B6 fou E3
et dame B7 il pourrait y avoir dame
prend C4
donc il peut y avoir déjà des petites
choses comme ça sur les variantes
principales un petit peu désagréableable
en tout cas alirea qui pousse à
4 j'ai l'impression qu'il joue tous les
les coups
principaux et qu' connaissent ils
connaissent vraiment ce qu'ils font et
alirea qui peut avoir le plan de jouer
cavalier D7 cavalier C5 hein le cavalier
qui pourrait revenir par là-bas faut
prendre des qu cavalier B3 ça peut
arriver j'aime beaucoup la position des
Noirs ça débute sur les chapeaux de roue
côté français alirea qui a l'avantage à
la
pendule comment doit continuer Magnus
l'ordinateur propose le truc logique il
fait cavalier C6 sur fou dame D6 il doit
avoir fou F4 et donc cavalier C6 dame B6
cavalier B4 dame prend
B5 avec ma foi un cavalier qui va vite
arriver en
C5
qui va même très vite arriver en
C5 donc il joue met le cavalier en C6
dame B6 va arriver qui prend B4 dame
prend B5 va arriver
aussi tout cas dame B6 c'est bien joué
prise en B5 prise prise en B4 prise en
B5 fou D2 va être joué ici puce que le
cavalier on n' pas envie de le déplacer
et cavalier D7 c'est d'ailleurs le coup
principal de la turbine aussi et après à
voir sur cavalier D7 si Magnus ne peut
pas juste rendre le matériel par
cavalier prend des5 ça c'est sûr que
c'est quelque chose auquel il va il va
réfléchir en fait ce cavalier en B4 il
est bien placé pour cette
raison mais là sur cavalier D7 pour le
moment on ne peut pas rendre la pièce
parce que la tour D1 ne rayonne plus sur
le pion D5 donc cavalier D7 il jouera
sûrement fou C3 avec à mon avis l'idée
de venir essayer de faire exploser cette
chaîne de pion et de faire vivre ce fou
de de case blanche s réussi à gagner
deux pions et installer le le fou des 5
après il pourra aller chercher C4 il
aura même l'avantage Magnus Carlsen
position vraiment très
intéressante pour cela qu'un coup comme
Toura D8 aussi est possible
c'est un peu le là que le le bas blesse
pour pour alirea c'est que ces pions ils
sont cette structure elle est magnifique
mais Magnus est bien en place après
cavalier C6 cavalier prend B4 pour pour
venir se sacrifier
contre contre les pions et faire et
faire vibrer le fou
G2 à position extrêmement
complexe cavalier
D7 fou C3 c'est hyper
logique D4 ça a pas l'air trop possible
donc il fait CER
C5 et c'est là que je me demandais
est-ce que les blancs peuvent prendre et
aller prendre en D5 est-ce que il est
dans le dans le bon
timing c'est une question très
intéressante à laquelle je n'ai pas la
réponse je n'ai pas la
réponse en tout cas c'est sûr que Magnus
il regarde des choses de ce type
là d'ailleurs dans les coups potentiels
de l'ordinateur il y a fou prend des 5
pu on prend des 5 et cavalier prend des
5 à titre
informatif mais c'est sûr ici que les
les blancs sont dans une situation où
ils peuvent potentiellement rendre la
pièce en tout cas il est réfléchi
Magnus c'est sûr qu'on regarde on
regarde et fou prend G7 puis cavalier
prend des5 et cavalier prend des 5
directs et fou prend des5 direct et fou
prend G7 et fou prend des5 et fou prend
G7 et roi G7 et dame 5 échec ici c'est
sûr que c'est toutes ces variantes là
sont possibles parce que si les Noirs
réussissent à s'installer durablement
avec les pions et à mettre la marche
avant ils seront gagnants après donc là
les Blancs ont encore le temps d'arrêter
cette marée de pion et ils peuvent
l'arrêter de manière extrêmement directe
comme je vous le disait simplement en
sacrifiant pour pour les gagner c'est la
manière la plus simple de de régler le
problème mais aussi la plus
efficace donc là Magnus qui réfléchit et
et il joue H4
ok il décide de ne rien
faire donc on n pas cavalier D3 pour le
moment pour couper les connexions à
cause de cavalier prend et dame prend
D3 est-ce qu'il va jouer tour
D8 est-ce que tour des8 est intéressant
sa rien c'est une question hein
réellement l'impression que Magnus va
essayer de jouer fouprend G7 H5 et mener
une attaque de ma en
fait en fait si on réussiss à faire tour
D8 cavalier B3 et D4 pour réussir à
recontrôler aussi la 5e rangée on serait
Gucci mais on est vraiment loin d'y
arriver HM
c'est
compliqué la solution simple entre
guillemets c'est H5 mais ça règle rien
parce qu'on va avoir G4 donc on repousse
le problème les blancs vont de toute
façon mener une attaque sur ce roi parce
qu'il considère que le roi éit celé H4
c'est vraiment un bon coup j'aurais pas
du tout osé mais on réussit pas avec les
noirs pour le moment à avancer et tour à
D8 menace pas grandchose à court terme
donc alira part pour cavalier
B3 alors là encore il y a plein de coups
pour les
blancs je pense pas qu'on puisse se
permettre de laisser la tour mais même
ça c'est
questionnable oh ça rentre tout de suite
dans La dans une complexité énorme hein
dès la première partie le combat est
intense les
amis dès la première partie le combat
est intense alors il prend G7
prendre un et laisser F8 ça paraît
bizarre donc il prend aussi maintenant
il y a deux pièces attaquer donc il va
jouer
quoi cavalier prend D5 qui menacera dame
5 échec à mon avis
fortement donc cavalier prend pion prend
tour
prend dame bouge et tour D1 seraitce
l'idée de de
Magnus
l'ordinateur donne plutôt dame E5 échec
avec idée F6 dame prend E6 euh wou bon
très franchement je suis un petit peu
dépassé hein c'est trop dur là et après
sur dame prend B4 il voudrait
quoi je suis un peu perdu là honnêtement
je je veux regarder parce que je je ça
me perd tu reprends des5 ah tout
bêtement et cavalier prend un
tout bêtement tour des7 et roi H6 dame 3
et roi H8 F prend à8 OK et T prend à 8
dame F7 bon un exemple hein des
variantes
possibles ça c'est juste un
exemple
ah ouais ouais ouais bon et cavaler il
prend des5 juste par curiosité puis on
prend des 5 t prend des5 alors là
attention tour F8 alors là attention
vraiment attention dame G4 admettons et
dame
B4 et tour à D1 ouais bon ça ça
ressemblait à la variante qu'on
avait extrêmement complexe comme
position extrêmement complexe il a joué
dame 5 c'estàd qu'il a compris que F6
dame prend E6 dame prend B4 t prend D5
c'était avantage décisif ouais bon ok
ils sont trop forts roi G8 il y a H5 qui
gagne donc F6 forcé non mais bon ok
c'est c'est n'importe quoi le niveau de
cette partie c'est n'importe quoi
ouais c'est c'est
déjà c'est du jeu parfait il y a plus
d'erreur et c'est deux malades qui
s'affrontent deux fou
furieux al je suis un peu dépassé parce
que tour A8 ça c'est ce que j'aurais
fait du coup si j'avais compris dame
prend D5 dame prend B4 et alors là
attention dame D7
ouais bon après il y a l'égalité
matériel à ce momentl donc pourquoi pas
et tour 7 tour prend à4 ah on n pas tour
prend D7 parce que tour prend D7 est sur
échec et il y a T pr B4 à la fin ouais
c'est c'est costaud c'est très très
costaud donc prend B4 et donc là si
Magnus fait une faute il bouge sa tour
bon il la bouge pas oua bon ils ont tout
vu évidemment donc là il va jouer tour à
7 il va jouer tour à 7 c'est sûr sur
tour à 7 il va y avoir tour AD1 et il va
jouer tour E7 tour D7 tour F7 et essayer
de de tenir comme
ça bon là les gars c'est c'est c'est
juste la PR enfin c'est juste toute la
partie c'est la première ligne en fait
au moins c'est simple on va pas faire
compliqué hein c'est-à-dire que là ce
que vous voyez c'est une partie parfaite
c'est 99,3 contre 99,1 de précision dans
une partie où il y a 40 pièces en prise
partout donc là si vous voulez c'est bon
voilà c'est merci au revoir en fait que
si vous êtes en face c'est merci au
revoir c'est même pas la peine de venir
en fait à moins d'avoir un plug après
mais sinon c'est même pas la peine là la
partie c'est c'est ciao en fait les deux
sont beaucoup trop
forts bon je pense qu'il va jouer tour à
7 il doit avec cavalier prend mais bon
il y a tour des 7 et fou prend à
8 et tour à 7 ça règle deux problèmes
ouais ça c'est joué c'est logique en
fait ça règle le problème de la tour qui
est en face du Fou et ça permet de de
régler le problème de la 7e rangée donc
tour AD1 tour7 tour D7 tour F7 à mon
avis on va on va gentiment se diriger
vers une nulle mais on est peut-être pas
à l'abri d'avoir d'autres surprises dans
cette partie elle est tellement complexe
qu'il peut finir par arriver une erreur
la tour7 c'est encore le seul coup après
c'est vraiment logique et tour D7 tour
FF7 parce qu'on a vraiment envie de
venir se recroqueeviller
ouais c'est
joué et tour des7 tour FF7 ça c'est
facile c'est évidemment le coup qui va
être
joué prends le 7 t prends le7 tour D7 le
retour t prend dame prend et sûrement
roi
H6
j' l'impression de jouer le gain avec
les Noirs mais
bon on va voir on va
voirour prend
ou non mais là il joue vraiment beaucoup
trop
bien c'est juste difficile de faire
mieux il va pas jouer tour des7 je pense
s'il le fait tu prend dame prend roi H6
ok bon ça c'était facile ro H6 c'est le
plus logique et là l'ordi donne égal
après dame6 euh
ouais il fait fou D5 ah il veut fou G8
et on peut pas faire un coup comme dame
D2
ici al dame D2 doit perdre mais je je
comprends pas trop
pourquoi c'est quoi le problème de dame
D2 Mo il fait dame D1 c'était quoi le
problème de dame D2 juste par curiosité
c'est juste pour comprendre la
complexité il y a dame F7 ah et on se
fait matter peut-être par dame F8 ok
bon et donc là c'est seul coup cavalier
des de non mais en fait si fait cavalier
des de là les les mecs ils vont il v ils
vont vraiment avoir envoyé la partie
parfaite c'est hallucinant je sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte en
fait c'est il y a pas eu une erreur de
la partie et là maintenant c'est dam à 7
seul coup non mais il y a juste pas de
faute en
fait mais dam 7 est-ce que j'ai pas un
coup comme A3 ah il va vouloir dame C5
après
habile
abilba dame à 7 sera dame C5 pour dame
F8 ah ouais la partie la partie est
violente par que dam 7 A3 donne
envie dam 7 A3 va donner envie et puis
on prend à 3 C3 peut-être qui serait
très très intéressant pour pour
alirea c'est ça qui peut lui faire peur
s'il a pas le le comeback en C5 Magnus
en difficulté c'est finalement lui qui
est sous la pression d'alireza dans
cette partie après avoir mis une énorme
pression avec les pièces blanches
Alireza en train de lui rendre mon de sa
pièce mais il trouve évidemment damass 7
ouais bon c'est
nimpe
arrêtez-les arrêtez-les mesdames et
messieurs ouais ok ils ont tous les
seuls coups ils ont tous les coups tout
le temps partout c'est genre de partie
qui é cœur ça me donne envie de
retourner jouer au petit chevaux là m'
l'air d'être plus un jeu dans mon dans
mon range les petits chevaux
non d'être un peu plus non parce que
là là c'est un peu Armstrong dans
l'usardiden quoi c'est te mettre la
petite tablee sur l'épaule c'est c'est
bien les échecs mais rentre à la maison
norement tu as préparé le goûter tu vas
boir le chocolat chaud quoi mais c'est
là c'est vraiment
ça là c'est le chocolat chaud mesdames
et
messieurs la position reste ultra
complexe
madameass c'est tellement bien
joué ah le niveau il est stratosphérique
he la précision là d'après d'après
Jean-Michel stockfish c'est combien
c'est 90 9 2 contre 991 mais c'est c'est
n'importe quoi je sais pas comment ils
font je sais pas comment ils
font la qui doit répondre il y a plein
de coups pour lui don dame F1 dame F1 ro
H2 dame2 bon et sur dame C5 du coup F5
bon là attention dame dame F8 on a on a
roi H5 bon ben comme le roi mais ne
protège plus F2 ça va bon on va pas
chercher à
comprendre mais oui ça passe Malal a un
peu stressé mais après dame dame F1
dame2 c'est pas illogique hein en soi il
joue
dame5 alors sur dame C5 il veut F5 et
dame F8 dame G7 c'est relativement
logique dame5 c'est relativement logique
il peut menacer dame prend B2 et revenir
sur cette diagonale en défense c'est
extrêmement bien joué encore de la part
d'alireza
ah il va faire F5 sur tout ce qui bouge
en
fait il jouer G7 aussi logique
d'ailleurs
ouais menace d' prend
B2 in à 3 à
2 une 09 chacun allez est-ce que est-ce
qu'un des deux hommes va va craquer
c'est possible là il va y avoir
A3 là à mon avis il va y avoir
A3 avec idée sur dame pr de faire
A2
pas sûr il peut aussi jouer dame
2 mais dame 2 dame 2 dam 7 roi h dame C5
on a peut-être perdu un tempo quelque
part
ouais il a fait
à3 logique très logique à3 B prend à3 C3
et dame D2 à voir on a peut-être même
dame prend B2 ou a prend B2
mais au pire sur dam des2 on a à de au
pire du pire du pire du pire du pire du
pire et sur B prend à3
C3 sur dame prend à 3 on a dame prend
D5 sur dame à7 on a ro H6 dame 3 on a
dame
prend alors peut-être ah je pense qu'un
des deux va finir par exploser dans
cette partie mais c'est déjà une partie
d'un niveau incroyable B pr à 3 C3 3 h6
il va revenir avec Dame C5 je
suppose et sur C2 comment il compte
jouer parce que C2 dame prend C2 il y a
dame prend
D5 quelle est son idée sur C2 sur C2 il
veut quoi il veut dame F8 d F8 H5 ah
j'en sais rien les amis c'est dur à
commenter et après dame
F7 et
H6 ah j'en sais rien il fait c de on va
bientôt le savoir ça et damage 7 et il
H6 et c'est - 7 tu es naz il est naz
Magnus il est mauvais il est mauvais il
l'a pas vu mesdames et messieurs sur G4
il ro prend H4 c'est ciao Magnus allez
ça commence par un punto direct ça
dégage il a pas le coup là
là il su il
su il est en train de suer Magnus il est
en train de suer du lourd il a pas vu H6
le frérot ouais bah c'est à Bonom là
c'est ciao dame des7 ouais ça s'appelle
une dame ça par contre fais gaffe parce
que ça bouge dans beaucoup de directions
Magnus quand même ouais il a préféré
abandonner et ça c'est un zé ouais c'est
pas la peine de de faire une tête un peu
zarb
ouais ça tu t'es pris 42 coups d'ordi
d'affilé monsieur c'est 42 fois d'affilé
la première ligne ça dégage c'est déjà
un zé c'est déjà un zéro mesdames et
messieurs ça commence très très fort
avec une partie absolument incroyable de
la part d'Al Reza qui n'a tout
simplement commis aucune erreur de la
partie c'est incroyable c'est juste
incroyable ce qu'on vient de voir une
partie immaculé d'erreur côté Alireza
Magnus qui a pu jouer le meilleur coup
40 fois d'affilé mais pas 41 c'est
dommage c'est pas de chance c'est pas de
bol mais ça perd c'est pas assez il vair
progresser
Magnus ah il va falloir s'entraîner à
bat stock fish 25 là si tu veux avoir
une chance dans ce
match
ah ça commence très très fort là ça
commence
euh ça commence de manière
impressionnante oh Magnus il a le seum
hein frère c'est pas la peine de
chercher des erreurs tu en as fait une
tuas tu peux pas mieux jouer en fait
ouais ouais B ok tu as le seum il a
complètement le seum tu pouvais pas
faire mieux frère tu étais au maximum de
ta force mais ça suffit à peine
ça ça me fait penser à Vegeta contre Son
Goku tu sais ouais frère bon ok tu peux
augmenter ton niveau tant que tu veux de
toute façon tu vas te faire fermer c'est
un petit peu
ça ah il vient de se prendre une gifle
là impressionnante ça lui a mis un coup
derrière la tête oh il vient de se
prendre une gifle ca lui a fait mal je
peux vous dire que c lui a laissé des
traces ca lui a laissé des traces à
Magnus
il se barre là il est il est grogy là il
est
grogy il est gros Guy
là il lui a mis une une mine mais alors
monumentale
monumental
vraiment monumentale
c ça va reprendre
là qui a les pièces blanches cette
fois-ci
ça essaie de descendre l'eau des
champions la S
pai allez ça
repart4 C6 D4 D5 la carocane ouais bon
ok tu as regardé un speedrun ouais bon
bravo Magnus ça regarde les speedrun sur
Youtube ouais bon on sait où il
s'entraînent mais bon ça marche ouais
bon là les vidéos que tu as pu voir
jusqu'à maintenant c'était jusqu'à
milelo
Magnus ça va pas suffire contre Al il
joue cette vante avec à 5 à4 que
beaucoup joue récemment avec cette idée
de venir contrôler la case
B3 donc alirea qui doit qui doit gagner
ce premier match he pour pour enlever
une vie à Magnus et repartir à Z0 mais
la partie qu'on vient de voir là juste
avant elle était vraiment incroyable
vraiment
incroyable il joue
F6 sur C carocan t pareil c'est un
peu positions elles sont toujours un peu
un peu bizarres à jouer toujours pas
facile à évaluer c'est tjour solide pour
les Noirs mais bon il y a quand même ce
problème
d'espace j'ai toujours beaucoup de mal à
les comprendre pour vous dire
franchement moi j'ai toujours envie de
faire C4 en fait toujour chaud de faire
C4 mais
euh
il met le fou en F4 alira mais
franchement là alirea depuis quand on y
pense il était tellement perte de
vitesse là l'année dernière et là va il
était déjà pas mal là il est hyper fort
et franchement s'il joue à ce niveau-là
au niveau qu'il a eu dans la partie
précédente c'est champion du monde hein
c'est VO ce qu'il vient de faire là dans
la partie d'avant c'est c'est du Maxim
prime c'est Maxime prime de chez prime
la la partie qui vient de sortir elle
est elle est hallucinante en fait c'est
je pense que vous réalisez pas ce qu'il
vient de faire c'est c'est genre
réellement dans une position difficile
que les meilleurs coups tout le temps
c'est je je c'est stratosphérique c'est
genre euh moi je sais même pas genre
quoi en fait c'est n'importe quoi de
jouer comme ça ça devrait pas exister en
fait c'est wouh c'était vraiment
fou donc il met le fou en F4 il contrôle
la case5 hein ça c'est logique comme
coup il veut se développer peut-être
mettre après le cavalier en D2 le puion
en
C3
ça réfléchit en tout cas maintenant côté
côté
Magnus ça paraît logique un f F4 on
vient vraiment gagner le la case
Magnus qui se met un peu mal au temps
elle est déjà capitale hein cette partie
pour Magnus dans ce mini match s'il perd
là avec les Noirs c'est terminé hein
ALARA va fermer la porte après mais
Magnus a encore sa deuxème vie qu'il
a
mérité si on prend F6 il veut quoi
cavalier prend il a pas peur du cavalier
qui arrive en E5
h ok ça le dérange pas
trop en fait il peut-être jouer puis on
prend
plutôt je suis un peu
débile et cavalier
H4
il fait cavalier
prend qu'il est pas gêné cavalier5 il va
juste jouer
G6 etchanger une fois et après jouer
pour fou D6 sûrement je vous ai dit
c'est pas toujours simple à sentir ses
positions l'impression que les noirs ont
des problèmes de case et puis en fait
c'est c'est hyper solide fait fou D3 k
G6
et fou
G3 D6 prend F5 prend F5 tour1 c'est pas
grave il va juste jouer ro F7 ok non
peut-être pas il aura peut-être remis le
cavalier en E7 je sais pas je suis un
petit peu
dépassé la partie d'avant a laissé
quelques quelques traces
incroyable petitqu de il accepte sur
foupron de se doubler les pion mais pour
contrôler les cases le long de la
colonne et jouer contre le pion
E6 je pense qu'il va
prendre
je pense qu'il va
prendre si on prend mais bon non les
blancs sont un peu mieux quand même il
contrôle les cases et il va pouvoir
attaquer le pion E6 mettre la dame en
B3 je préfère les blancs même si la Jae
met 00 comme vous pouvez le
voir
ça réfléchis je regarde moi aussi les
cames un petit coup pour pour
jaoger Magnus qui a pas l'air au
mieux le début de match étit
retentissant il prend une fois en G3 bon
là je pense qu'on s'invente pas de live
on prend de
H et cavalier j'ai
4 menace
rien pour le
moment il met le cavalier en
B3
il peut faire
C4 et mettre la tour en
C1 tu peux jouer C4 mettre la tour en C1
et
rentrer maison après moi j'ai depuis le
début de la partie je veux faire ce plan
avec
C4
qu'est-ce qu'il peut nous faire d'autre
peut-être jouer juste tranquille tour 2
dame des2 tour1 et se placer peut-être
tour de c'est pas bête en
vrai il fait dame de ouais non c'est pas
bête de venir un peu protéger ce truc
là c'est peut-être pas
bê
sur F PR5 il veut pion prend et dame
échec ça suffit pas pour l'avantage
peut-être le cavalier B3 il est bien
enfermé dans les pions adverses quand
même
ok il va jouer tour puis cavalier C1
cavalier D3 je pense il va faire
tour
t F8 prend 6end bizarre de pas avoir
fait tour F8 et là je pense qu'il va
faire cavalier C1 pour cavalier D3
cavalier 5 mais il y a ro
F7 il peut peut-être faire tour D6 pour
tour D7 tour B7 ah c'est peut-être pas
bête
ça après cavalier C1 roi
F7 avec la
tour cavalier C non c la première
intention quand même c'est relativement
logique F7 c'est cavalier G5 d'ailleurs
excusez-moi j'avais
raté qui est
fort propose
F4 cavalier D3 FG FG
je suis pas convaincu
c'est mieux pour les blancs ça c'est
sûr ça c'est vraiment sûr 614 contre
540a qui réalise un très beau match pour
le
moment il trouve F4 quand même pas
étonnant parce que c'est un coup
vraiment
logique
il va sûrement mettre le cavalier en D3
maintenant c'est fait prise G3 prise
g3ord propose du B5 maintenant pour pis
on prend pu on prend et C3 tour à6 quand
même ça fait un peu peur il ve peut-être
jouer avec B4 et jouer sur le roi qui
est peut-être en réseau de math
bizarrement ça peut être un
thème ça peut être un
thème mais bon et cavalier F6 plus
logique il va jouer C3 je pense un bon
coup de
stabilisation
C3 c'est un B coup de stabilisation mais
ça peut préparer B4 aussi peut-être pour
qui s aller créer un un pion passé à
l'aile à l'
dame joue cavalier E5 cavalier prend
cavalier
prend il peut aussi jouer pour P on
prend et cavalier D4 ouis ça a l'air
vraiment un peu mieux partout pour les
blancs après après il faut réussir
à à trouver
comment transformer
ça il faut réussir à trouver comment
transformer
ça cavalier5 qui va vouloir jouer quoi
parce que si son plan c'est B5 il t
prend C6 quand
même
c'est quoi l'idée sur B5 t prend C6 t
prend C6 qui prend C6 B prend A4 qui
prend à 5 on sa javis il dit que ça
c'est nul oui bon enfin il est très
gentil hein mais personne va rentrer
là-dedans
ouais donc en fait l'évaluation elle est
complètement tronquée c'est jamais plus
020 en fait si la seule solution c'est
B5 et ba c'est non mais personne va
faire ça en s'il le fait c'est un génie
hein mais
après il va pas le faire c'est
infaisable pour moi cette variante donc
non c'est énorme avantage blanc B ça
peut faire 2-0 là en l'espace tu as
peine eu les temps con le tu as à peine
eu le temps de cler des yeux que Magnus
il est déjà il est déjà aux abois il est
déjà terminer le frérot ça va être Chao
là le premier
match ça va être Chao mais d'une
puissance bah ouais c'est 5 t prend B6
c'est prend D4 ok ça c'est évidemment
plus humain comme défense mais bon il y
a encore B4 après puis on prend tour
prend t prend C2
ouais bon c'est pas si clair c'est pas
si clair C5 est bien joué évidemment
tour prend B6
DC et là le seul coup pour gagner c'est
B4 et sur pion prend il veut quoi
peut-être à 5 même
direct je sais pas c'est compliqué non
alza je pense qu'il va jouer plus ah
cavalier C6 cavalier C6 c'est logique
cavalier C6 roi F7 cavalier prend D4
il veut quoi sur B4 AB il veut A5 t
prend C2 ah il y a tour B8
désolé désolé désolé j'ai oublié ce ce
mat là en
retour en fait il menass pas vraiment
reprendre ces
de
ouais c'est hyper
compliqué c'est hyper
compliqué il fait cavalier C6 du coup il
a raté
aussi euh
ouais roi F7 cavalier prend D4 tour C4
je suis déc avec le chat du coup je
comprends
pas tout ce qui se passe mais bon c'est
pas facile à commenter à analyser en
même temps mesdames et messieurs c'est
hyper tactique et c'est hyper
intense
ah donc c F7 qui prend D4 et ouais non
ça va pas
suffire t C4 t B7 3 si C3 tour à 4
cavalier e 6 ouais
c'est c'est dur B c'est ça c'est l'idée
ouais
ouais du coup c'est roi E8 seul
coup il prend les qu tour C4 tu laisses
G7 ouais non mais
c'est en fait là les les coups euh les
coups humains sont pas les plus forts
roi G6 en fait et roi G6 c'est comment
c'est cavalier 7
évidemment roi G8 c'est cavalier au7
ouais donc en fait tu as pas trop le
choix ro E6 c'est cavalier
D4 roi 8 c'est cavalier D4 aussi
c'était bien joué de commencer par tour
B7 mais ça c'est
égal c'est pas vraiment
égal ça c'est pas vraiment
égal la tour qui revient en B7 à mon
avis cavalier 4 ah cavalier prend C3
et si on fait B3 ah il y a cavalier4
quand
même mais B3 cavalier 43 cavalier ici ro
F4
il y aura du
tour1 ça va pas être
assez mais si on fait roi E3 t prend B2
roi F4 t prend G2 roi E5 essayer de
monter je pense que je partirai pour ro
E3 on prend B2 et roi F4
mais il y a cavalier H5
pardon donc pas
possible on peut le faire que s'il fait
cavalier E4 en
fait donc tu peux pas cavalier4 ro F3
cavalier
C3 roi F4 ouais donc il part pour Cid là
qui peut faire marcher que comme
ça il peut pas faire ça autrement sur
cavalier D6 t prend
H7 donc il va prendre C3 et il veut roi
F4 ro F4 il y a pas tour1 à cause de
pion pr pour le moment
ouais c c'est cette ligne là il réussit
à la
faire donc là il menace
rien mais il peut pas décal la tour
parce qu'il a le cavalier C3 en
l'air c'est hyper bien joué de la part
d'alira en fait il a réussi à faire
marcher cette idée qu'on qu'on voulait
faire mais il l'a fait
précisément et là Magnus Magnus est en
immense
difficulté cavalier A4 alors là il va y
avoir
B3 cavalier C5 tour
B5 cavalier D3 roi
F5 ça l'air hyper fort on va
voir
ah il fait tour un maintenant c'est
malin ah ça c'est bien
joué ah ça c'est bien
joué donc c F5 je pense comme ça sur
tour4 tu auras cavalier E6 donc c F5
tour
E4 cavalier E6 donc il va jouer cavalier
C5 tour
B5 tour E4 c'est tellement chaud et
cavalier C6 peut-être à la fin pour
cavalier E5 et roi E6 après
c'est très très très compliqué plus que
de 10 contre une 10 la par partie est
bouillante mais alirésal à la minute de
plus dans une partie aussi complexe elle
met très très très bien je peux vous
dire que la différence de temps là elle
fait du bien on sent Magnus qui suit
cavalier C3 allez maintenant on va
ramasser H7 il est temps de prendre un
pion et d'envoyer l'autre ah je pense
qu'il est temps de manger là il est
temps de faire ce festin et de s'offrir
l'autoroute allez al
Reza il est temps de le manger ce Punto
et après G4 G5 G6 G7 G8 au bout du bout
ça peut y
aller qui prend son
temps il réfléchit à cavalier E6 aussi
hein mais cavalier E6 il veut cavalier
E4 je pense il couvre la case il menace
k D6 et prend
g3ors que tour prend H7 cavalier E4
façon fait G4 on avance
non
ouais il prend H7 c'est bien tour
G1 et on peut pas juste jouer tour H 2
un coup de
fin pour pousser le pion tranquillement
après que tour c'est un coup de F c'est
pour bloquer la tour et et s'ouvrir le
pion on leur dit donne tour C7 mais
tourage j'aime bien est-ce qu'on a pas
un tel coup de fin
il fait roi E6 qui aussi un coup de F ça
menace mat en
un cavalier F5 qui va faire
quoi cavalier F5 il fait quoi menace mat
tour échec roi F6 cavalier
E4 tiens encore mais t on peut pas faire
peut-être juste ro
D6 il fait ro F6 Caval 4 3 G6 le roi qui
se barre de l'autre
côté 7 échec intermédi
tour5 qui menace le pion et allez
maintenant G4 allez petit il faut nous
l'envoyer au bout lui faut pousser là
juste en fait
pousse là faut juste pousser je pense là
juste on pousse en force simple allez ça
part ça part il a 1 2 3 4 cou à faire
encore lui roi des7
pousse faut juste pousser en
fait à un moment donné on peut même
avoir un cavalier 7 prise 5 et ro H6 et
poussé mais je pense faut juste pousse
en fait il fait cavalier 3 cavali 3
c'est pas mal aussi W en fait c'est une
fourchette
je l'avais pas vu mais c'est juste une
fourchette en fait ça c'est un pion il
le prend du cavalier mais c'est un pion
ça attaque son cavalier et ça c'est un
autre pion Magnus
et ça c'est un autre pion
ça c'est cavalier C3 c'est une pièce en
fait c'est juste une pièce Magnus allez
hop ça dégage la racaille on veut plus
le voir on ne veut plus le voir ça
s'appelle de0 ça
c'est de Z là les amis
c'est facile is c'est on est facile on
est très très facile c'est le champion
du monde en face
ou c'est juste le champion du monde ou
c'est quoi en
face c'est c'est pour savoir en fait
c'est s'ils ont pas quelqu'un d'un peu
plus fort à ramener TASCOM là il y a pas
un petit message qui peut partir là pour
rench il y a pas il y a pas plus fort
parce que c'est un peu c'est un peu gaz
là en face en fait c'est un peu facile
c'est c'est vraiment le vainqueur du
tableau des des gagnants ou c'est
ouais j'ai pas j'ai pas c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas des des des niveaux de jeu
qu'on a l'habitude de suivre
ici on nous avait habitué à mieux en
face on nous avait habitué à beaucoup
mieux là c'est c'est très tranquille
il a été vraiment facile il a vraiment
été
facile il a vraiment été très très
facile là
liera
il a vraiment
défoncé mais ouais mais c'est ce que je
vous avais dit la barre d'évaluation
elle donnait 0 mais c'est jamais 00 ces
truc là genre ça elle donnait quasiment
égal mais c'était nimpe en fait ça c'est
jamais égal ce
truc bah ce truc aussi ça donnait égal
mais c'était jamais égal en
fait c'était jamais égal cette partie
c'était trop dur à jouer avec les Noirs
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a bien joué là
lia
il a été il a été
exceptionnel ouais c'est c'est très très
fort c'est très très fort là ce qu' fait
alira 2-0 donc maintenant il faut une
nulle dans la partie 3 ou 4 et et on
ira
et on ira vers le prochain
match on ira vers le deuxè match il a
quasiment perdu sa vie Magnus déjà mais
il aura encore le deuxième mini match
pour pour peut-être
l'emporter en tout cas lza il a vraiment
été bon là il lu a sorti deux
masterpiece
donc là il a besoin d'une nulle àira sur
les deux prochaines parties ça lui
permettra de gagner le premier match et
donc on partira dans le 2uxè match qui
sera au meilleur des deux
parties
mais ouais non la
position position était
vraiment trop
forte c'est quand deè match ce sera
après mais là le premier match pas
terminé
encore
za est grandissime favori évidemment 2-0
c'est quasiment impossible de remonter
après faut toujours se méfier hein il
vient bien d'en gagner deux d'affilé à
liresa donc c'est possible d'en gagner
deux d'affiler dans l'autre sens aussi
hein
en tout cas c'est un
beau un beau début de match on s'y
attendait vraiment pas contre tout
contre toute attente
CIRA pose des problèmes à Magnus ça oui
mais qui viennent lui mettre 2-0 d'emblé
c'est c'était c'était moins
évident
on va voir s'il continue à sur ce rythme
là
alira en tout cas là il a joué des
parties mais d'un niveau incroyable
vraiment
incroyable
alle ça vient du loser bracket
exactement c'est exactement
ça
mais après là Magnus il peut pas trop
s'en vouloir he il est juste tombé sur
plus fort que lui pour le
moment
c'est combien de match ben ouais là
c'est bo4 et puis bo2
après
ah je fais un petit
tweet je fais un petit
tweet je vais mettre la lumière moi
aussi je vais m'allumer de la lumière il
fait sombre chez tout le monde en fait
les joueurs et moi-même
on va aller se mettre une petite
lumière ça va reprendre à mon avis dans
3 4
minutes
en tout cas la première partie elle
était vraiment incroyable
hein
[Musique]
HM on attend je récupère un peu
d'énergie
Magnus en fait il va rallumer la la
caméra au moment où il va lancer
hein
est-ce que c'est
reparti
non
a l'air
concentré ah ils sont full sans pè je
crois qu'ils sont à l'hôtel
[Musique]
du du truc en Allemagne
là allez il va reprendre Magnus qui
rallume l'ordi la caméra
plutôt les joueurs qui vont probablement
reprendre Diou la peur de gagner
maintenant je crois Pasin je crois juste
qu'il va le défoncer après le de
deuxième match c'est c'est moins
clair mais ce premier match je pense que
c'est un peu dans les
mainsin un peu dans la poche je mal
Magnus revenir mais bon il faut faire
attention il faut va falloir le fermer
quand
même
je profite de l'interv pour te remercier
tout ce que tu fais en partie par que si
passant pour les débutants merci à toi
Boudi allez on se
lance dans cette 3oème partie alira qui
n'a besoin plus que d'un match nul pour
euh pour aller chercher ce ce 3è ce ce
deuxème match cette deuxème petite
finale ou cette dernière finale je sais
pas trop comment l'appeler en tout cas
pour enlever une vie à Magnus et c'est
le système de Londres qui va être joué
et on va voir ce qu'alirea va opposer à
ce système de Londres est-ce qu'il va
jouer le système avec C5 avec fou F5 un
système avec E6 et B6 fou B7 et le fou
derrière il joue
C5 système qui ressemble à celui qu'on
avait fait dans dans la vidéo petit R to
vous pouvez retrouver sur Youtube si
vous le
souhaitez si vous en avez marre de
perdre contre le système de Londres on
vous avez fait une petite arme avec
Mathieu Cornette et là normalement le
coup c'est cavalier
D2 à base de CCO assez joué assez
rapidement alors ici sur dame B6 l'idée
c'est qu'on a dame B3 et sur C4 dame C2
fou F5 dame prend F5 dame prend B2 il y
a tourb à la
fin mais il y a les variantes de notre
notre ami le coangliem mais je me
rappelle jamais comment ça
marche il peut jouer juste avec F F5 ici
he c'est
OK fou F5 est ok comme
coup ça marche pas comme c'est pas dame
B6 dame B3 C4 dame C2 E5 puis on prend
E5 fou F 5 non c'est pas comme ça
j'arrive jamais à me rappeler comment ça
marche ce chest B de de Leang j
arriverai jamais faut que je me le
procure en tout cas fou F5 ça va ici ça
c'est sûr enfin ça va censé aller si
c'est un peu
triste il va jouer avec fou
D6 il s embrouillé ala là il s'est
embrouillé mesdames et
messieurs il s'est
embrouillé alors pas que ce soit grave
mais il joue pas ce qu'il a envie
d'avoir il a pris pas mal de temps je
crois qu'il sait pas exactement ce qu'il
fait il a un vrai
problème avec le fou
C8 fallir vite le régler peut-être en
jouant fou D7 cavalier B4 et fou
B5 il commence par rock mais ça c'est
pas grave entre
guillemets peut-être juste fous des7
hein il va jouer à 3 là-dessus c'est
sûr il joue B6 il veut jouer B6 A5 et F
A6 aussi possible là il va jouer a
5 mais à 5 dames de les blancs qui
peuvent encore interdire le l'échange
des
fous après je crois qu'il y a un plan
c'est de faire un truc alors tu peux
faire à 5 dame2 peu importe mais fou B7
cavalier E7 cavalier F5 cavalier
E4
je crois qu'il y a un plan comme ça qui
existe alors je l'appellerai aussi le
plan de Fab par que c'est Fab qui m'en a
parlé mais moi je l'aime pas trop parce
que j'ai l'impression que tu te prends
G4 G5 et tous ces trucs là mais je crois
que tu as un plan de FME un peu comme
ça alira là il s'est fait prendre dans
l'ouverture il lui arrive ce qui doit
pas t'arriver c'est-à-dire d'avoir ce
fou enfermé là-bas en
B7
ça c'était pas pas l'objectif de
l'ouverture il fait le plan de
Fab ouais il va falloir vraiment gérer
le le truc hein pour
Aliza
tour à C8
ok il va vouloir jouer ouais ce plan
cavalier 4 cavalier F5 si tu arrive à le
mettre en place ça va mais faut faire
gaffe de pas se prendre des G4 ou ce
genre de
chose ok bon position doit aller he pour
le
moment qui a le problème de se fou B7
mais qui peut vivre un peu par
procuration en mettant un truc en
E4 mais ouais c'est un plan de un éemme
plan de Fab tout
ça il y a tellement de planans de Fab
dans ce
monde mais il y a qu'un
Fab mais il n'y a qu'un
Fab non je pense qu'il va il va mettre
cavalier E4 cavalier F5 en next next de
coups G4 bon là faut le prendre hein ça
c'est un
Pun il veut cavalier G4 F H7 ro
H7 cavalier G5 ro G8 dame prend
4 ça paraît quand même
dangereux il va faire Caval 4 al il va
pas le
prendre trop
dangereux l'ordi kiffe mais c'est trop
dangereux en fait l'ordi kiffe parce
qu'il te fait ça ça ça ça ça ça ça et
ça mais visuellement c'est dangereux
et je pense que Ali va prendre peur en
fait Caval super bien placé parce qu'il
tient la case H7 et il tient la case
F7 et c'est les blancs qui se font
contrer je pense pas qu'il trouve B si
ouais voilà cavalier4 c'est ce que je
vous avais dit cavalier prend G4 c'est
trop
risqué c'est pas le genre de coup qu'on
qu'on joue
généralement donc il joue cavalier4 le
coup
logique
ça c'est le coup logique qui a valu au 4
mais ça va la position est
correcte et on me demande comment
comment va Fab comment va Fab ça c'est
une bonne question et bien écoute notre
ami Fab va extrêmement
bien il ne peut pas aller mieux et et si
tu veux on va faire un stage avec lui si
tu souhaites le voir si tu souhaites
voir Fab on va faire un stage avec lui à
Taline cet été donc tu auras du du Fab
et des nouvelles du Fab de cette
manière-
là ce qui est très beau hein bien
évidemment voir Fab c'est toujours
magnifique donc le cahier qui est venu
en
G5 il vient taper sur le cavalier
E4 je sais pas siil peut jouer F5
ici puis on prend puis on prend et sur
dam H5 dame G6 je pense qu'il veut faire
quelque chose comme
ça il prend G5 il va faire E5
alors là faut faire
E5 mais genre
vraiment là je pense faut vraiment faire
E5 et menacer E4 en fait si quand tu
fais E5 si prends tu prends bon tu peux
prendre en C si tu as envie avant mais
là faut vraiment faire
E5
je la sens pas du tout cette
partie je la sens vraiment pas du tout
cette
partie s'il fait fou B5 fou prend C6 qui
ramène un cavalier en E5 ah fallait faut
il règle pas le problème de son fou B7
en
fait il ne règle pas le problème de son
fou
B7 mais ça c'est
un
c'est un
problème ça c'est un vrai problème le
fait qu'il qu' le règle pas et FO 6
alors il joue pour le plan où
euh o F prend à 6 dame prend à6 il veut
rentrer mais il il règle le problème du
fou fou B5 était peut-être plus fort
alors fou prend à 6 dame prend à 6
peut-être cavalier
E7
peut-être F prend à 6 dame prend à 6
cavalier e
7 peut-être une
[Musique]
optionut prend à 6 dame prend à 6
cavalier7 cette partie est d'un moins
bon niveau que les deux précédentes hein
il y a une baisse de régime de tout le
monde mais ça reste avantage blanc ça il
y a pas de il y a pas de
question bon là la ligne principale de
l'ordi était introuvable il a fait
cavalier G6 j'ai peur qu'il ait dame B7
T c si
là
malera qui s'est laissé embarquer dans
un combat stratégique qui lui convient
pas et qui a pas réglé les problèmes de
la
position je pense
qu'il il pourra s'en vouloir de pas
avoir jouer le 5 là au moment où j'en
parlais le reste de la partie c'est
vraiment une domination de Magnus là ça
y est il est rentré le long de la
colonne
C et là il fait
mal là il fait mal il a raté trop
d'opportunité àa dans cette partie il va
laisser Magnus revenir au
score va falloir faire nul avec les
blancs dans la prochaine
ouais j'ai pas de il y a pas de solution
là je crois
5 comme seule chance pour vraiment
tenter quelque chose mais il a pas fait
à tellement de reprises je pense pas
qu'il le fasse là il va empêcher tour
C6 mais système de
Londres c'est toujours un un
problème il a gardé son fou derrière les
pions et il a pas réussi à à régler le
problème de manière correcte et après
Magnus a joué fou A6 un peu à bon essant
pour rentrer dans la colonne C et sur
tour B8 je pense qu'il doit y avoir tour
C8 ou dame C7 dame C7 encore plus fort
dame prend C7 t prend C7 et on se fait
mal axè par la tour
dame B8 on peut échanger et faire tour
C7 quand même avec les Blancs non faut
le seul coup qui peut ouais 5 ouais
c'est le coup qui joue en fait il a
compris que tout le reste perdait en
ligne et donc il devait finalement jouer
au 5 à ce momentl donc il a compris la
bonne idée mais avec pas mal de
retard et sur D prend5 faut qu'il tente
D4 puis on prend et dame D5 ah il y aura
encore tour
C7 et puis on prend est-ce qu'il peut
tenter cavalier prank cavalier prend
dame prend G5 cavalier F3 dame prend E3
roi G2 dame E2 roi G3
non peut-être qu'il doit tenter hein
d'ailleurs c'est le deuxième coup de
l'ordi quasiment le premier qui prend le
5 il fait
des4 et tour des6 intermédiaire ouais
bien joué donc dame
8 ok bon qui prend le
5 ou puis on prend le3 et pu on prend 3
dame
prend3 et cavalier prend 5 et prend 5
dame prend 5 dame prend D4 d prend
G5 reste
dur plus qu'une 30 pour alza mais Magnus
qui quand il impose son style est plus
fort tout
simplement il a jou cavalier
prend5 dame prend d prend
G5 alors Didon égal il y a quoi il y a
un pion de moins mais le roi blanc est
un peu ouvert ça je veux bien le
comprendre aliarza qui est peut-être en
train de finalement dans une partie très
décousue de remporter ce match il va
peut-être jouer h H5 tour D5 dame G4
prise G4 prise G4 prise à5 donc non il
va jouer quoi peut-être une partie très
décousu en train de remporter ce premier
mini match va peut-être jouer dame B5
alors dame B5 qui semblere une
option avec idée d'aller toucher la
case2 mais dame B5 peut-être tour D8 al
peut-être va jouer h6 il joue dame B5
c'est le coup que j'aurais joué en
première intention au final ça vient
toucher la case 2 quand même donc je
pense qu'il va jouer dame D2 Magnus et
peut-être à ce moment-là
H6 et c'est vrai que s'il met la tour en
B8 après ça va être vraiment
égal il va jouer là un petit coup de H6
ah on sent qu'on a besoin du H6 H6
peut-être ah mais H6 tour D5 ça va H6 t
D5 on a dame B8 mais dame B8
dame5 dame B3 tour à5 dame C2 ouais
c'est
dur peut-être jouer dame B8 direct en
fait dame B8 directement peut-être mais
B4 donc il fait
F5 F5 G5 F4
oh
là ça force la
finale on prend le 3 c'est obligatoire
tour B8 c'est
obligatoire faire prend vite
là il tour B8 direct ça change pas
grandchose il est en train de finer pour
rien on prend prend tour B8 tour 5 tour
pr B2 ça c'est nul il va jouer tour D2
et V 3 F7 3 G6 alors peut-être
mais bon plus que 25 secondes contre
550 ça va être très compliqué pour les
deux hommes très compliqué pour Magnus
de gagner mais aussi très compliqué pour
alirea pour faire
nul la nul suffirait à gagner ce ce mini
match en tout cas Magnus qui met une une
grosse pression dans ce système de
Londres c'est son style de jeu on l'a
dit et il fait parler la poudre
desescampettes tour des de rois F7
faut vraiment faire r F7
là il aura tout le temps de jouer tour
B3 et A4 si le roi s'approche là le truc
c'est que roi il va revenir vers
C2 la H4
maintenant et il y a un
problème H3 tour D4 h H5 C C2 tour B5 et
les blancs vont mettre la tour en D4
avancer le pion alza qui va
s'incliner dans cette partie qu'il aura
relativement mal
maîtrisé la Magnus calcule si tour des4
gagne en
fait avec l'idée tour prend H4 t prend
H4 il fait tour D7 oua mais là le truc
c'est que tout gagne on ne vibre même
pas et maintenant il va mettre la tour
en
D4 et
maintenant
tour à 4 et tout tout gagne t prend à
5 et les pions qui
filent c'est hyper
facile pour Magnus
Carlsen B5 a même pas de
suspense il n'y a même pas de suspense
dans cette
partie ah Bona tente le tout pour le
tout il a
raison mais bon
là alira qui s'est fait dominer de A à Z
il faudra revoir sa copie sur le système
de
Londres il va devoir revoir sa
copie le pomb qui arrive sur échec et
tour à8 tour
C8
Magnus qui revient à 21 et vous l'avez
vu remonter ses
manches il espère bien égaliser là de
buts à si gagne sal il s'ofrirait
l'armagedon dans ce premier
mini il est revenu un tout petit peu au
score
alle qui prend une petite pause il a
raison de casser le rythme il vient de
perdre une réellement mauvaise partie de
sa part et surtout ce qui est un petit
peu ENF embêtant ce qui est un petit peu
moche c'est que ça a paru
inéluctable il s'est fait il s'est fait
marcher
dessus s'est fait rouler dessus petit à
petit
voir ça récupère un peu de
temps les deux premières parties étaient
très tactiqu la trisème était plus
stratégique quand ça était plus tactique
ça été en faveur d'alira quand ça était
plus stratégique ça était en faveur de
Magnus
maintenant c'est Magnus qui se lève
voilà il y a beaucoup de psychologie là
attendu de voir que kalalireza revienne
pour lui-même recasser le rythme c'est
bien joué de la part de Magnus ça joue
un peu au jeu du chat et de la souris
Magnus qui veut s'imposer
psychologiquement
terrible allez il
revient deux hommes sont là et le le jeu
qui devrait reprendre est-ce quea va
jouer au 4 ou D4 on va voir Magnus dans
l'obligation de avec les
noirs allez il
joue4 C
5 qui va devoir décider quel sicilienne
jouer il ouvre la Sicilienne il a raison
à mon avis une siilienne
ouverte qu' a beaucoup de Var de nul à
gauche à droite et c'est le dragon qui
est choisi par Monsieur Magnus
Carlsen
F3 fou G7
F3 il y aura pas de variante de nul bien
évidemment Magnus qui joue avec H5
rapidement pour empêcher
G4 ça va jouer au jeu du chat et de la
souris évidemment dans cette
partie C4 F D7
allez çab un petit coup de un petit coup
de
sampé PR D4 il prendre de la dame ou du
fou c'est pour ça qu'il hésite il joue
fou prend fou
H6 va juste faire fou3 fou
G7 mon avis ça va juste reculer avec le
fou
et fou G7 ici je pense non il échange je
F G que j'imaginais qu' voulait garder
plus de
pièces la position a l'air parfaite là
pour pour
Al tour C8 fou B3 je dis parfaite dans
le sens où on a besoin de nul je
rappelle et là il va jouer petit rock je
pense je pense c'est grand le coup mais
je pense qu'il va partir pour petit rock
c'est ple petit quand même
petit rock c'est extrêmement pleutre
quand
même non il fait grand
rock et c'est bien joué de la part de
Magnus là vous voyez toute la
psychologie dans ce coup d'AM C5 Magnus
qui lui dit je suis plus fort que toi en
finale et même si je suis obligé de la
jouer je je préfère te torturer en
finale que de jouer que de jouer une
position à double tranchant et alira qui
lu dit ok jou la finale c'est là là il y
a une bataille psychologique qui se qui
se met en place chez euh chez les deux
hommes une vraie bataille psychologique
ici est-ce qu'il va accepter de de
rentrer dans cette finale ou
pas est-ce qu'il va venir prendre en 3
il a jouer ou est-ce qu'il va continuer
à jouer un peu à à ce jeu de dupe en
jouant petit rock tout en sachant que
les les blancs pourront toujours rentrer
dedans tout cas lirea qui relève le gant
de son
adversaire et qui accepte
de jouer
potentiellement le match nul en
finale chois som tout intéressant et B5
de la part de Magnus alors l'ordi
déteste à cause de E5 le coup le plus
logique en plus5 c'est le coup que je
aurais proposé automatiquement pourquoi
est-ce qu'on regarde 5 dans cette
position on a les deux tours braqués sur
le roi le roi est au centre donc on veut
tout ouvrir c'est le coup le plus
logique dame prend E3 tour prend E3 et
c'est joué par
Alireza et là tour prend5 et et j'ai
envie de dire Magnus pourquoi tu joues
parce que B4 semble être le seul coup
mais après cavalier E4 cavalier prend
E4 t prend E4 A5 il a fou prend F7 3
prend F7 et T prend
D7 ok donc A6 non donc c'est A6 le seul
coup et là il y a juste tour D6 ah tour
D6 il a tour C6
pardon j'ai dit une
bêtise j'ai dit une bêtise donc il a
joué à 4 mais bon à 4 ça a l'air
fort c'est vraiment avantage non je
crois que l'ordi avait un gain mais
quelque chose de vraiment complexe et
maintenant tour des6 ça a l'air vraiment
fort genre là tour des6 ça a l'air
fracassant par qu'il a plus tour
C6 je vois pas comment il
défend
bon pas
trouvé mais là il y a du t tour des4
tour B4 maintenant peut-être pour juste
aller gagner le pion physiquement qui a
l'air hyper fort ouais tour D4 tour B4
ça a l'air hyper
fort ça ça a l'air vraiment fort et
facile euh
ouais est-ce
[Musique]
que
ouais est-ce qu'il y a autre chose par
que genre cavalier D5 ça a pas l'air un
mauvais non
plus D5 prend D5 prend D5 fou6 t D3 fou
prend B3 B3
bon tu vas pas la
perdre allez faut pas que faut pas qu'
fasse n
là après peut-être qu' des prise D5
prise D5 fou e 6 tour D3 fou
F5 bon il fait c D5 ouais c'est le truc
humain je raconte pas complètement
n'importe quoi toujours
tour
des7
bon
il va pas falloir faire n parce que s'il
perd
celle-là ça va faire mal à la
tête et là il m'a pas l'air je sais pas
je le sens pas je sens pas serein je
sens pas dominant
ala en fait sur T prend D7 D7 F7 roi D8
pour ceux qui avaient cette idée
hein ah il a pas il a pas ce qu'
attention àirea
là
attention attention parce que bahà les
tour C5 cro C3 il va se prendre B4 j'ai
l'impression qu'il est en train de de de
de de se faire des nœuds dans la tête
tout
seul allez roi C3 roi
B4 je
pense et s'il amène le RO en B4 ça va
bien se
passer le roi va être bien de dominant
bien en face du
pion il est pas serein il va se prendre
E5 F6
G5 regardez c'est en train de se mettre
en
place oh là là là là là là là là oh les
nœuds dans la tête là qu'il est en train
de se faire
àirea
là il est pas serein il est pas
serein ah je le sens venir gros comme
une maison la vi la sens venir gros
comme une maison la victoire de Magnus
là évidemment pour le moment alza est
énorme favori mais on sent qu'alza il
fait tout ce qui en son pouvoir pour se
mettre dans le problème allez H3 faut
stabiliser cette structure tu es obligé
là maintenant de de te stabiliser sur
case blanche oh il va y avoir G4 qui va
arriver puis on prend F prend G2 il
commence à passer par derrière la
oh là là alira qui est en train de se
faire des nœuds dans la tête ah c'est
psychologique là ah il s'est
complètement écroulé il avait la
position gagnante il s'est mis à jouer
pour faire nul et là on a l'impression
que petit à petit il est en train de
glisser alira
ah il fait peur là il fait peur il fait
très
peur
la France a peur mesdames et
messieurs échange en D7 une fois fut
prend D7 allez faut faut mettre ce pion
C tour A7
peut-être voilà rien que le fait d'avoir
Magnus en
face
ça le fait
suer ça le fait
suer alira qui
réfléchit mais ouais il y a rien de
précis à dire dans cette partie juste il
se fait des
nœuds dans la tête tout seul comme un
grand
il fait C4 il
échange H 3 G3 ça c'est son plan depuis
tout à l'heure il est obligé de le
suivre C6 il va faire
faire
F tour F1 j'aime pas du tout ce qu'il
fait hein je sais je sais pas quoi
commenter quoi dire précisément mais je
trouve que c'est juste visuel on voit
les blancs qui je sais pas qui pédalent
dans la
semoule tour A7 il y a ro F6 tour à3 il
y a tour
B8 il va devoir jouer tour F1 c'est la
tristesse du
joueur
là Magnus il sait qu'il a énormément il
a il il a vraiment des chances de la
gagner qu'on sent qu'a il est
complètement à côté il réussit à rester
quand
même assez solide dans son langage
corporel ala mais il fait peur il fait
peur il fait extrêmement
peur là c'est la peur qui nous
domine et ce à
raison
ah il faut peut-être jouer tour F2 fou
F1
maintenant h là l'ordi aime bien F4 pour
GF tour prend F4 c'est un bon coup
solide ça
ou roi C3 pour revenir les deux en
fait
ou roi
C3 mais tour F1 c'était bien joué pour
bien
consolider mais il se met mal au temps
il fait tout ce qu'il faut pas faire et
ça paraît inéluctable on a l'impression
que ça va aller petit à petit et que ça
va finir par
perdre c'est
terrible C3 on a vu de fois ce scénario
se reproduire quand Magnus Carlsen est
en face faut vraiment jouer F4
là faut vraiment le faire ce F4 prise et
prise on protégera le fou avec le pion
ça y est il le
faitz ça c'est peut-être une bonne
nouvelle au moins la partie va devenir
plus tactique à un moment donné où il
lui reste encore un petit peu de de
temps
il est mis sous pression
alirea mais pour le moment il réussit à
faire le Doron il plie mais ne ront
pas là le F4 est
salvateur donc sur fou D5 a toujours B3
et le clouage ne peut pas être
appuyé c'est la bonne
nouvelle
G4 ça permet d'avoir tous les pions sur
case noire pour les blancs donc ça va et
si prend tour prend fou D5 B3 E5 tour
H4 on va essayer d'aller choper le pion
le pion H3 je pense c'est un pion passé
seul normalement on peut pas aller à
Dame fait fou G2 ça donne tourd1 échec à
mon avis intermédiaire il veut quoi sur
tour tour il veut fout des5 W il est
malin donc tour F2 bien joué Alera il
tombe pas dans le
piège
allez c'est bien tour F2 bien
joué et puis on prend F4 t prend F4 donc
il joue avec
G4 il faut peut pas vraiment jouer avec
B4 parce qu' a fou D5 mais peut-être un
petit coup comme B3 pour le moment
histoire de stabiliser la position il
fait tour des de fou D5 B3 c'est très
bien ah le petit B3 qui vient
stabiliser il va essayer de passer par
derrière avec la tour et là ce qu'il
veut Magnus c'est avoir accès à la case
G2 pour venir poser un problème éternel
à Aliza et là l'ordi montre un joli coup
c'est F5 et c'est joué par Alire Reza
allez c'est bien F5 ça peut permettre
d'avoir tour D4 t prend G4 et après
mettre la tour en H4 mais attention hein
position
est toujours
aussi
tendue la vie d'alirea ne tient qu'à un
fil faire gaffe il pe des positions il
se retrouve avec un pion d un pion h
passé ça peut être réellement très
dangereux je pense qu'il va mettre la
tour en A1 puis on prend6 puis on prend
E6 oh là il y a fou2 s'il trouve fou 2
c'est bon fou 2 ferme la partie il peut
plus gagner si alirea trouve fou de
c'est gagné s'il trouve pas fou de c'est
hyper chaud et il a Let's Go Magnus a le
seum il a le seum parce qu'il est en
dessous une nouvelle fois il a le seum
parce qu'il est en dessous ça c'est sûr
on connaît ce scénario côté
Magnus il a raté le fou2 fou prend G4 et
ça y est alirea va réussir à la gagner
c'est abandon
instantané le SE est colossal côté
Magnus Carlsen ce fou de il a fait
tellement mal mais tellement mal ah ça
l'a complètement
fermé et c'est un premier match gagné
pour Alireza on va avoir le match
retour on va avoir le match retour
maintenant mesdames et messieurs et ça
fait plaisir donc le score c'est de
nouveau
0-0 qui va devoir aller
chercher la deuxème finale et maintenant
ça va être au
meilleur
de deux
parties ça va être en deux parties
maintenant et le premier à un point et
demi changement de règle Magnus n'a plus
qu'une vie dans ce tournoi et là c'est
la petite pause qui
s'impose
fut2 qui faisait si mal parce que ça va
aller chercher le pion G4 he tout
bêtement de manière
imparable
bon
en tout cas en tout cas céit un beau
match mais c'était que que l'entrée
c'est maintenant que les choses
sérieuses vont
arriver donc 2 et demi 1 et demi le
premier match est terminé donc on
revient à une vie partout et maintenant
ça va être le deuxième match alors je
sais pas
oùc nous le met j'imagine que les
parties sont
ici là il va y avoir une petite pause he
évidemment
c'est un PR d'abandonner et pourquoiil
accepté au lie de forcer l'abandon parce
que en fait nul gagne le match je sais
pas comment
dire nul ou abandon c'est
pareil donc là
maintenant on reprend un match 20 en
deux parties
qui éint sa
cam et Maxime avit déjà battu deux fois
Magnus en
finale c'était déjà
arrivé
de parti c'est pas peu pour une finale
il y a déjà une première préfinale en
quatre parties donc après je suis
d'accord qu'il pourrait avoir un
deuxième match en quatre parties mais
ils sont ils se sont peut-être dit que
c'était trop
les copains anglais disent n'importe
quoi une mus win game Magnus gr ouais
mais il av faut prendre G4 faut prendre
H3 il pouvait plus gagner en
fait
donc ouais il raconte un peu nimpe mais
c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas nouveau en fait ils
essayent d'inventer des histoires qui
sont pas forcément réelles autour de ce
qui se passe pour que ce soit vendeur je
pas trop comment
dire
je mets un petit
tweet c'est la finale après la finale
après la finale là c'est exactement ça
Ludvig la c'est la finale de la finale
de la finale là c'est la der des der des
der des
der donc ouais je voyais hein tout à
l'heure des gens qui m'ont qui m'ont
réécrit pour le stage qui posaient des
questions le dans le chat
vraiment écrivez directement un mail à
Fab ou quoi là on est sur les
commentaires vous me demanderez en live
mais écrivez juste à Fab ou sur un live
que je ferai plus tard mais là on est là
on est ici
pour pour voir pour voir le match mis à
part vous dire que c'est du du 10 au 17
juillet je peux pas vous en vous en dire
beaucoup
plus c'est ni le lieu ni le ni le
moment je pense ça va repartir dans 5 10
minutes à mon avis
là
non non là c'est pas fini c'est c'est
maintenant là le là c'était c'était
c'éit le moment de le mettre sous
pression là on l' on l'a pêché déjà
Magnus il va être temps de le faire
mijoter
maintenant
voilà c'est la der des der des der des
der ouais c'est
ça c'est bon SIG quand Mme qui est plus
solide qu'avant en final complètement
ouais
en tout cas l il va vraiment être
content de de sa semaine son niveau de
jeu il le retrouve de de compétition en
compétition
et ça c'est très bon
signe
il est sur gr il faut allumer le feu
pour faire le faire griller c'est
ça il faut le faire
griller il faut le mettre dans le air
Fryer dans le air
Fryer
là c'est normal he qu'il ait une
pause c'est quand même éprouvant
physiquement c'est
match c'est quoi le cas Price c'Est
30000 je crois pour le premier plus une
qualification pour la grande finale plus
des points dans le truc où il y a plein
de fric aussi à gagner
donc pour gagner ce c'est un peu comme
gagner au moins 70000 € à mon
avis
Magnus devait pas se
penser repartir pour un match à
rallonge je crois qu'il attaque avec les
Blancs non
attendez ah c'est la grande finale 2
d'accord non
grande
finale j'ai je sais pas où j'ai les
parti où sont les
parties grande finale 2 ça y est on est
là alier RA qui a les pièces noires et
Magnus Carlsen il sort mon répertoire
d'entrée mesdames et messieurs et oui il
envoie il envoie la trompovski et pas
étonnant dans les grands moments qu'on
sort ses meilleures armes et donc alira
qui joue avec D5 et
C5 Magnus qui joue le l'idée avec
cavalier D2 donc c'est une manière on
prend plus vraiment F6 on naime plus
trop les varantes avec GF mais du coup
on joue avec les Blancs quelque chose
d'un petit peu hybride c'est un joueur
de système de Londres mais avec le fou
en G5 et c'est assez malin là ce qui
fait Magnus il veut obtenir exactement
la même partie que la même même type de
position que dans la partie qu'il a
remporté mais avec quelques petites
finesses alors est-ce que alirea va
jouer dame B6 ici pour aller taper sur
le pion B2 il prend des4 une fois puis
on prend des4 et là on va avoir une
structure de type Carl bad je vois bien
alirea sortir le fond F5 non il joue H6
d'abord et maintenant mettre le fond F5
ah faut pas qu'il rejoue une partie où
il se fait enfermer hein ce fou mais là
attention à lirea qui va jouer
contre la structure de prédilection de
Magnus Carlsen la structure Carls bad
alors inversé pour le coup mais c'est un
spécialiste mondial de de ce système de
jeu et on va voir si S réussit Alireza à
tenir tête au G ou pas allez il faut
vite sortir le fou en D6 et roqueet ne
pas perdre de temps ici alors il peut
aussi jouer fou 7 les deux sont
possibles mais il faut surtout
jouer allez fou D6 petit rock
et là il peut se permettre de jouer un
coup comme dame C7 les Blancs ont
peut-être pas très envie de de prendre
directement en F6 donc il peut peut-être
jouer dame C7 et retarder le le petit
rock en tout cas il réfléchit à lira et
c'est ce qu'il fait c'est très bien joué
il règle entre guillemets le problème du
clouage de cette manière en ayant
retardé son rock et la pression
maintenant est sur les épaules de
Carlsen c'est lui qui doit jouer un bon
coup ici et il fait fou3 qui est
probablement la meilleure décision
possible prendre en F6 c'était vraiment
dangereux et donc il revient en G3 il
vient contrer ce fou ce fou D6 à mon
avis ala va juste prendrequ il va pas se
casser la
tête il va juste prendre
herquet il joue H5 aïe aïe AE a AE a a
mesdames et messieurs il va partir pour
grand rock il va partir pour grand RCK
cet homme est un fou furieux
je comprends pas ce qu'il fait H5
G6 alors là il va jouer pour ro F8 3 G7
il va faire cavalier G4 je pense l'
intertermédiaire pour toucher la
case3 à mon
avis c'est ce qui va
jouer mais W H5 pour G6 venir anticiper
la poussée et se garder le la
flexibilité du roi c'est tellement
ingénieux on se rappelle d'une partie un
contraire d'os où il avait mis son roi
en D7 c'était au championnat d'Europe
par équipe et là il joue un plan
encore original une nouvelle fois où il
se maintient toutes les possibilité de
développement du roi c'est rarissime he
d'avoir ce ce genre de
chose aux
échecs resa il va quand même devoir
jouer quelques coups conventionnels à un
moment donné
parce que c'est quand même particulier
he cette structure de pion toute sur
case blanche avec le foot case blanche
c'est un peu je sais pas on voit on voit
quand même pas mal de trous là qui
s'illumine c'est pas mauvais mais c'est
quand même ah c'est quand même un peu
risqué Magnus Carlsen du coup qui envoie
l'attaque à l' dam il envoie B4 il va
partir pour A4 pour A5 pour
B5 ça c'est le plan al raza qui va
probablement décaler le roi un petit
coup en B8 histoire de pas avoir de
soucis sur la colonne
C mais j'ai l'impression que le roi
blanc est beaucoup mieux protégé que le
roi noir et qui va être compliqué pour
pour alirea de de se débrouiller dans
cette partie après il peut peut-être
faire un petit blocus joueur cavalier E7
B5 dame D6 A5 et quand le le pion arrive
en contact bouger de l'autre
côté donc il peut peut-être anticiper
tout ça avec cavalier E7 et peut-être
jouer pour cavalier G8 cavalier F6
cavalier E4 il joue F6 qui est aussi
hyper logique pour G5
H4 à mon avis Magnus va jouer à 5 ici il
va aller s'enfoncer dans le camp
adverse cavalier H4 intermédiaire très
bien joué sur
F6 il veut souligner quelques problèmes
genre sur G5 cavalier prend pion prend
F3 le cavalier n'a plus le la CE de
retrait en F6
Magnus Carlsen en train de de faire un
récital
ici ah il joue extrêmement
bien dans cette partie Magnus Carlsen
ala qui a qui veut trop en
faire et là on le sent en petite
difficulté Magnus en plus qui garde un
bel avantage à la pendule et le cavalier
en H4 bien placé tape le fou tape le
pion quelque part ils sont pas il fait
il fait perdre
de Al je disais que le cas il sera
enfermé il peut peut-être repartir vers
H6 après mais bon il serait très très
mal
placé il serait très très très mal
placé après est-ce qu'il doit faire ça
ou pas peut-être
hein peut-être qu'il doit quand même
partir pour quelque chose comme
ça G5 cavalier prend F5 prend F5
ouaord fait même juste à 5 on est même
pas obligé de faire F3 direct en fait
les pièces noires sont complètement
bloqué c'est
terrible c'est terrible non mais là le
placement de pièces des noir est pas
terrible cavalier tu veux le ramener
vers F6 de toute
façon do jouer cavalier7
d'abord pour pouir jouer G5 cavalier
prend et reprendre du
cavalier
mais là le placement de pièces des noir
est trop trop trop
étrange moi j'ai vraiment pensé qu'il
jouerait pour petit
rock beaucoup trop optimiste
Alireza me propose aussi un coup comme
eu 5 il va falloir prendre une décision
comme ça qui est un
peu bizarre stratégiquement
[Musique]
mais
mais qui semble être
indispensable
euh ouais G5 jouer bah il va partir pour
cavalier prend pision prend
comme je disais F3 et cavalier H6 encore
que j'avais raté dans un premier
temps on leur dit dame D3 à 5 il y a
beaucoup de coups qui vont là pour les
blancs on sent que c'est difficile de
percer la la muraille de Carlsen parce
que ce cavalier F1 il tient bien la
baraque il tient la case H2 sur laquelle
on pourrait connecter
facilement et jou fou D3 ou il vient
taper sur sur F7 sur F5 pardon il va
provoquer F4 de toute façon on va bien
devoir régler le problème du y mais les
pièces noires sont tellement
désordonnées
alirea qui fait une une mauvaise partie
ici il a il a il a trop trop forcé le
type de
position il a trop forcé son type de
position et maintenant il
souffre et maintenant il souffre plus 4
minutes contre 8
824 mais la position va de mal en
P faut qu'il trouve une manière
de de renverser la
table au moins vraiment changer la
nature du
schmilblck mais là c'est dur de
comprendre comment
faire
la structure des noirs est vraiment
mauvaise faut vraiment tenter F4 fait
cavalier7 c'est une autre option de
toute façon il y a pas il y a plus de
Bonn ou mauvaise options ici il y a
juste une position difficile qui va
falloir réussir à
gérer je suppose qu'il va vouloir jouer
avec
H4 je suppose qu'il va vouloir jouer
H4
ça semble être pas
idiot et sur dame 7 il doit vouloir
quelque chose comme tour 8 je suppose
mais il a peut-être fou B5 sur sur dame2
il veut dame prend
C3 dame prend7 dame prend D3
ingénieux c'est très ingénieux
c'est très ingénieux de la part
d'Alia de vouloir de vouloir avoir ce
dame Fran C3 parce que dame 2 c'est le
coup qu'on va en premier dame prend C3
j'arrivais pas à trouver donc j'ai voulu
m'aider de la turbinette et ça il l'a vu
évidemment donc ça explique pourquoi la
turbine veut tour E6 en premier
H4 et sur tour à E1 il veut
HG FG et tour H7 ça c'est l'idée
d'alierza puis tour H8 et mat
ok écoutez il a réussi à faire quelque
chose quand même et donc l'ORD veut quoi
il veut tour6
H4 F3 à ce
momentl mais bon puion on prend P on
prend F4 franchement et vous en pensez
quoi un petit zip comme
ça avec idé tour H4 tour H8 genre
tour H4 prend7 t
H88 d C8 t prend C8 t prend C8 cavalier
prend G3 puis on prend G3 et il se
trouve qu'il y a roi F1 à la fin mais
bon ça ça peut être
chaud ça il faut y croire côté Magnus ça
peut faire très très peur ce genre de
chose c'est pas fait encore c'est pas
fait alors ça gagne et c'est pour ça
qu'on voit une jauge comme cela pour
pour les blancs mais c'est pas fini
c'est pas fini mesdames et messieurs il
y a de l'attaque pour Alireza quand même
ça se voit visuellement on comprend que
ça ça doit pas marcher pour les Noirs
mais après quand on est en partie il
faut trouver Magnus qui commence par F3
alors ça c'est malin parce qu'il veut
pas laisser oua il fait tour mtenant
c'est très malin en fait c'est très très
malin il a pas voulu laisser ce que je
vous ai montré alors comment est-ce
qu'on peut arranger leou on a du mal on
a du mal c'est bien joué de la part de
Magnus c'est très très bien joué de la
part de Magnus ici il a pas laissé ce
pion s'installer en G3 et lui poser des
problèmes
il a pris le problème à la racine et
maintenant sur h6 il peut même juste
prendre en
H4 et on ouvre rien du
tout il prend le problème à la
racine al comment jouer pour
Alireza il fait tour F8 sur tour1 il va
vouloir cavalier
G8 ah c'est triste il va faire cavalier
G6 mais c'est triste c'est triste parce
que la la tour c'est un peu notre gloire
sur la colonne h ah ilce quand même
partir en C8 pour défendre
oh la tristesse du joueur
et maintenant à 5 Magnus qui contrôle
l'entièreté de
l'chiquier allez il va falloir essayer
d'échanger un
truc mais ouais on arrive vraiment pas à
toucher ce TR on arrive juste pas même à
à le à le mettre dans le moindre
danger cavalier D6 allez il
essaye ah c'est terrible il se fait
enfoncer on va devoir jouer B6 hein
façon partie pour partie mais maintenant
la 7e est est
sensible il y a même pas d'idée de
cavalier E4 ou quoi ça marche
jamais
bien malin s'il peut défendre
Alireza cavalier qui arrive en E3 il y a
toutes les pièces de Magnus qui qui
dévalent quel
cauchemar est-ce qu'il va tenter un
cavalier4 un genre de Desperado puis on
prend puis on prend essaie d'aller
prendre en
G3 c'est
l' il fait dame D7
7 alors il a quand même une idée sur
cavalier prend D5 il veut cavalier
4 il doit dire qu'il va faire tour 7
dame prend D5 puis on prend
E4 ça a l'air la C D5 cavalier4 tour 7
ah a cavalier prend D2 intermédiaire
pardon je suis complètement
débile je suis complètement débile mais
bon il a tour prend B6 et puis on prend
E4
ouais de toute façon il y a plein de
coups qui gagn en
fait il y a tellement de C qui gagne
il y a tout qui gagne en fait on peut
prendre un4 avec n'importe quelle pièce
et reprendre
ouais non il y a il y a rien il y a
rien j'aiessayé de j'ai carrément oublié
la dame tellement tellement les noirs
sont acculés non'ont pas de
menace
mais bon pour magnusà en partie c'est
vraiment facile après c'est une question
de
choix mais l'erreur elle est pas
tactique dans cette
partie l'erreur elle est pas tactique
elle a été stratégique ouais bon la
position elle
est horrible horrible absolument
horrible C4
C5
ouais
c'est ou B5 ouais enfin il y a tout qui
gagne regardez juste la position du roi
les blancs on même pas de retard
matériel c'est
ouais c'est
vraiment une
horreur il va essayer de revenir en G4
avec le cavalier je pense pour essayer
de créer une
incertitude si on peut appeler ça une
incertitude
d'ailleurs là il est complètement acculé
là complètement
acculé il va falloir égaliser avec les
blanc par que je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait s'en sortir indemne ici
il prend B5
ouais bon il franchement il se débat il
se démène mais bon C4 dame à 5 cavalier
B4 je vois même pas comment on arrête
cavalier B6 cavalier C6 a peut-être même
plus fort pour les
blancs il se bat encore quand même il
donne tout
on espère que Magnus fasse une gaffe en
plus le pire c'est que sur C4 dame D1
qui est B4 il peut même pas prendre en
D4 et qui C6 qui prend des4 à la
fin c'est genre juste difficile de
trouver des coups de
défense bon pour le moment sur cavalier
B4 il a peut-être tour C8 c'est pour ça
que il se précipite pas dessus mais C4
avant ça paraît vraiment
fort Magnus qui veut quand même être sûr
de lui il
tank d'accord ben
écoutez parce qu'il a tourb1 aussi qui
est fort mais mon tour B1 il va tenter
Dame prend B1 prend B1 t prend
des5 en fait il y a tellement de bon
coup là pour les
blancs c'est fou ça trop de trop de gain
tue le
gain trop de gain tue le gain pour
Magnus
Carlsen il y a trop de choses qui
gagneent sans
forcer
trouve C4 qui est le plus
fort 5 et cavalier B4 C8 à mon
avis seul microscopique
chance
sur pr
56 faire cavalier F5 à la fin pas le
choix tour D6 ça de revenir plus ou MOS
au même
et cavalier C6 de toute façon c'est
obligé à là de toute façon faut éviter
cavalier C6 ça attaque trop de chose
donc il va bien falloir donner une tour
dessus hein fait tour
C8 et là Magnus il a le choix il a même
l'embarras du
choix même jouer un coup comme fou F3
pour réparer
tour7 mais bon F F3 il cavalier F5
encore qui tient la
baraque mais allez parfois la seule la
seule chance de tenir parfois c'est que
l'adversaire se fasse un peu des dans
des nœuds dans la tête et se mette mal
au temps c'est ce qui est en train
d'arrivé dommage qu'Al a pas joué tour
C8 un peu plus vite pour se garder une
bonne trentaine de secondes mais il a
encore 19 secondes et Magnus qui veut
faire trop bien les
choses qui sait ça peut
coûter il fait cavalier C6 t prend C6
dame prend à 5 pu on prend à 5 fa prend
C6 il va jouer cavalier F5
ici il va être obligé d'aller prendre le
pion A6 aussi à un moment donné là il
faut qu'il fasse cavalier F5 il va y
avoir D5 C prend A6 dommage qui c'est
vraiment très dommage qu'il soit mis si
mal aut temp par que je vois des petits
potentiels dans mes variantes que je
calcule d'arnaque genre roi prend C5
tour D8 tour E6 et peut-être cavalier
ici tour prend F6 qui prend C6 t prend
C6 roi B5 ce genre de truc ça peut
parfois allez tour D8 tour e 6 cavalier
D4 par normalement ça marche pas mais je
veux dire on peut avoir un micro espoir
mais pas avec 7 secondes parce que sur
D6 peut-être on peut faire cavalier
prend qui
sait donc ça cavalier D4 et et là l'ORD
dit donne fois 4 échec mais fois 4 seul
coup qui gagne mais c'est trouvé ouais
il a forcément vu parce que sur cavalier
prend6 puis on prend le pion file à Dame
donc là il doit jouer roi a 7 forcé et
maintenant tour7 et
D6 il a été propre he
Magnus il a été extrêmement propre très
très très bien joué
tour C8 il réussit encore à placer un
petit problème sur D7 tour D8 et roi
C7 il joue encore un excellent coup
Magnus il a tellement bien joué la
finale T 4 cavalier F5 mais c'est pas
encore complètement fini D7 t D8 C6 C7
et là on peut pas jouer t pr
C5 à cause de tour 8 d'abord et
D7 il a été parfait Magnus il y a rien à
dire ah il était il aurait un peu moins
de temps ça temps le temps aurait été
inversé il y aurait une petite chance
genre là par exemple
ça c'est même déjà gagnant pour les
Noirs parce que les pions peuvent plus
avancer mais il a réussi à avoir F 4 il
a eu t il a vraiment tout eu et là on n
pas pr C5 à cause ce qu'on vient de voir
et donc les noirs sont complètement
fixés
parce que s commence par D7 3 C7 t 8
tour d5on encore tour C8 éche quand même
qui gagna mais
bon il a été très bon
Magnus il y a rien à dire et maintenant
c'est lui qui a eu nul de la victoire
Magnus
Carlsen c'est lui qui a eu nul de gagner
cette
finale mur maintenant dans l'obligation
d'égaliser
ah c'est
terrible c'est
terrible non
su
Magnus qui a vraiment été très très bon
hein bon c'est peut-être la dernière
partie de cette première étape du
champion chestour 2024
si alira firouja ne réussit pas à
l'emporter ça en sera terminé
il a vraiment bien joué il a vraiment
bien joué il y a rien à
dire il y a vraiment rien à dire il a
été il a été
meilleur il a été bien
meilleur
à c'est must win maintenant c'est must
win must win must
win allez ça repart déjà E45 cavalier F3
cavalier C6 et fou C4 l'italienne al fou
qui
envoie une position où on va garder
beaucoup de pièces sur les
chiquers C5 fou G5 H6 F H4 et le fou qui
revient E7 c'est pas la première fois
qu' on voit ce système D6 à4 et ouais le
fou qui est repassé derrière la la
structure maintenant que le fou blanc
est arrivé en G3 allez ala qui peut
encore jouer hein pour C TR D4 bêtement
personne ne lui interdit de prendre le
centre et d'avoir ce petit avantage hein
quand même C TR cavalier D2
D4 tout est encore possible pour Alireza
il a les pièces blanches avec les Blancs
on n pas complètement son destin entre
les mains mais on peut quand même à
minima mettre la pression he sur
l'adversaire il met la tour en E1 il va
préparer gentiment
D4 allez il a une
position correcte à r une
position prête pour le
combat G6
Magnus préfère prpare peut-être
l'arrivée d'un fou en G7 plus
tard du cavalier en H5 peut-être
même peut-être même plutôt du cavalier
en H5 en fait le truc c'est que sur
cavalier H5 il y avait cavalier prend5 C
prend G3 cavalier prend C6 et donc avec
G6 il prépare cavalier H5 surtout
peut-être faut faire H3 alors cavalier
H5 FO
H2
simple il faut peut-être pas se
compliquer la
vie il ne faut peut-être pas se
compliquer la vie mesdames et messieurs
il faut peut-être juste aller cacher ce
fou en
H2 et pas s'embêter plus que
ça G6 en fait il veut ça et il veut il
voudra plus tard F F8 fou G7
h
ok tour 8 et maintenant C3
ok C3 ça va
aussi
ok Fall jouer avec
ouis je pas c'est vraiment compliqué là
il faut à mon avis prendre le
centre jouer des4
maintenant ve jouer tour C mais bon
pour ça je comprends même pas l'utilité
du
coup non tour c'est1 c'est trop
bizarre soit dame D2 tour D1 D4 soit D4
direct mais si on peut faire
D4 cavalier B5 peut-être pour se placer
là-bas H4 je suis pas
contre
par que sur G5 on peut repartir on a
quand même affaibli des cases plutôt
bien
joué H4 et vous avez remarqué que Magnus
a vraiment changé son son fusil d'épaule
pour pour ces parties joue beaucoup plus
vite
là les deux premières parties il était
pris aut temp par
ala là c'est plus du tout le
cas est-ce que va décider de prendre et
jouer pour cavalier D5 C3
B4
je pense pas parce que les noirs peuvent
encore chasser le cavalier par
C6 Magnus par qui a complètement modifié
son sa manière de jouer là c'est fort ce
qui fait
Magnus il joue plus vite le cavalier D5
ouais6 ah il doit prendre à mon avis du
Fou et faire
C3 il fait C3 direct il a vraiment pas
peur de G5 G5 fou G3 fou pr il peut
toujours reprendre
ouais non c'est bien
joué ah peut-être cette fois-ci il va
prendre F6
intermédiaire et après prendre en D5 et
jouer sur le foot case blanche ah ça ça
peut être pas mal faut prendre D6 dame
prend F6 Pr pr prendre
D5 ah ça qu'il s'en fiche encore de de
G5 il en a vraiment rien à faire G5 fou
G3 ça l'intéresse pas il prend C6
intermédiaires ah c'est bien joué ça et
maintenant il va jouer pour cavalier D2
caver C4 cavalier E3 cavalier F5 wouh
mesdames et messieurs il a été hyper
fort là
alira il a été hyper là il va juste
faire cavalier D2 si les blancs prennent
en G3 ah je pensais qu'il vouit
reprendre de F et jouer G4 mais là il va
juste se décaler avec le cavalier c'est
prochains coup c'est juste cavalier des
deux il va jeter un œil par là-bas et
après au pire il va revenir par
ici je pense va juste faire cavalier d
de il fait des4
c'est bien joué aussi D42 était possible
pour le coup mais D4 c'est aussi très
et ouais parce qu'il menace pu on prend
et sur P on prend la structure sera
dégueulassé côté noir et sur pion prend
D4 il veut prendre F4 puis prendre D4
ala qui sort une grosse game
là il sort une très grosse game
alirea peut peut-être gagner sur
commande mais il fait extrêmement mal à
à Carl en
CE début de partie un petit peu comme
comme dans le début de match un match
qui a fini par
tourner un petit peu en faveur de
Carlsen enfin début de match du coup là
qui est qui a plutôt tourné en faveur de
Carlsen depuis la 3oème partie
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt Magnus qui
domine mais là ça y est alerza a repris
le contrôle donc je pense qu'il va
échanger et partir avec le cavalier vers
C4 alors là s'il trouve le coup de
l'ordi Magnus
bravo bon il a pas trouvé le coup de
l'ordi c'était tour prend B2 dame prend
B2 et cavalier D3 si tu trouves ça bravo
mais il a pas trouvé donc dame
E6 il voulait empêcher cavalier C4 et
maintenant il va jouer G4 mais G4
H4 donc là B3 il veut il veut mettre le
cavalier en
C4 et il va toucher le pion à 5 et un
petit peu le pion E5 au passage aussi
mais surtout cavalier E3 cavalier
F5 le temps par rapport à la position
qu'Alia a obtenu il est plutôt correct
puisqu'il a 6 minutes 02 contre 730 mais
il a beaucoup de temps encore pour jouer
il a une position hyper
agréable et Magnus qui a raté le petit
tour prend B2 mais il essaie de jouer
vite Magnus donc quand tu joues vite
l'avantage c'est que tu peux mettre la
position la pression sur la
penduadverse convénient c'est que tu
auras un peu plus de Scor dans dans ton
jeu comme comme ça a été le le cas le
cas
ici en tout cas
B3 vient gagner le le contrôle de la
case
C4 et une fois qu'il est en C4 il tape
sur A5 et comme je le disais il peut
revenir vers E3 et F5 donc il va aller
toucher une case là-bas puis une case
ici alle plus que 6 4 pour Magnus il le
rattrape autant et au mauvais moment il
a réfléchi un coup trop tard Magnus fou
F8 maintenant il veut jouer fou C5 donc
cavalier
C4 un truc c'est que si tu fais prend 5
et cavalier que tu reviens ouais bah
voilà la question que j'allais vous
poser c'est que là il a de l'attaque
Magnus mais si tu gagnes le pion à5 et
que tu reviens
aprèsah toutes les finales sont
gagnantes pour toi et ça fait mal ce
pion à 5 c'est un pion passé
éloigné ça me fait penser un peu à ce
que me disait mon mon entraîneur murtass
quand tu gagnes un tel pion après il
suffit de faire nul et c'est gagner dans
les dans les dans l'esprit c'est
histoire de dire après si tu réussis à à
subir l'attaque à échanger les pièces au
lieu de faire match nul à la fin tu
auras parti gagner il va faire G4 c'est
sûr mais
H4 vois pas comment il ouvre en fait H4
cavalier H5 on peut peut-être même
partir en H1 la dame défend F2 et après
si on met le fou en G3 qu'on échange un
moment
donné ça fait mal hein si le pion arrive
en B4 A5 et commence à s'approcher de de
ton de ta 8e rangée Magnus et vous avez
bien compris ce que je voulais dire à la
place de 8e rangée ça va faire mal
alleza qui qui continue de s'hydrater
c'est
bien peu de Samp l'au des champions
cavalier H5 ro H1 alors l'ordi là
propose G3 en coup principale mais non
pas
G3 ve G3 pour ro G2 fou G1 et sortir
plus tard
c'est quand même c'est
costaud G3 c'est
costaud s le fait bravo mais
Bonin il y avait une petite différence
entre les deux coups mais oui le truc
principal enfin le truc principal le
truc humain c'est Dame F6 G3 à quoi je
pensais pas la variante principale de
l'ordi mais après on va remettre le
cavalier en C4 sil réussit pas percer
Magnus on va peut-être
avoir
un Armagedon
final en tout cas ça joue très très très
très bien côté
Alou qui a remis quelqu Barb allez fou 3
maintenant le coup solide c'est bien
c'est parfait prise prise dame F2 et ben
voilà la la théorie de Murtas
ah il veut dame prend F2 fou prend F2 et
gagner des pions
ça a pas l'air très grave parce que en
fait le temps qu'il amène ses quatre
pions à dam on peut pas juste prendre
prendre mettre la tour en B1 laisser G3
bouffer C6 et envoyer une option à
Dame on peut peut-être
pas enfin on peut mais peut-être que ça
gagne pas j'ai l'impression que les
pions noirs ils vont mettre tellement de
temps à arriver par que regardez le pion
F7 il a tellement de mal à rejoindre
l'attaque t ouais c'est pas c'est ouais
c'est pas la ligne principale de l'ordi
mais c'est hyper logique prend G3
cavalier C6 tour B6 qui B4 puis A5 en
fait une fois qu'il aura pris les deux
pions avant de créer un souci avec ce 4
contre 2 on a le temps de recevoir des
SMS des alertes météo je sais pas quoi
là c'est c'est Météo France he le truc
il préviennent 5 jours avant qu'il y a
l'orage he je vais te dire il va pas
aller faire dam c'est c'est ces cion là
ils vont rien
faire
et la menace là c'est ro H2 si tu prends
pas le
pion le prochain coup c'est ro H2 et tu
as as juste un pion de moins pour rien
il est en train de se faire murtassifier
Magnus il fait F5 ah F5 c'est un bon
coup voilà là je reconnais mon Magnus là
je reconnais mon Magnus F5 très bien
joué il s'en fiche de prendre les pions
il veut aller jouer sur sur alunic Punto
je pense faut pas le prendre parce qu'au
moins quand il arrive en E1 on file une
cale je pense faut aller prendre ici et
revenir vers D5 genre cavalier C6 t B6
CER
D4 puis on prend cavalier D5 t D6 qui C7
enfin je pense qu'on peut aller
peut-être essayer de prendre trois pions
et après
pousser un peu comme comme devra pousser
le 15 de France ce weekend en
Écosse du côté de
murfield
je pense qu'il va faire ça après il y a
aussi l'option tour F1 à vrai dire vous
prend G3 on prend
F5 vous prend H4 et même peut-être B4 et
on prend C6
après ça va aussi enfin les deux sont
possibles maintenant il va falloir
prendre une décision
àira il faut pas avoir peur de Magnus là
ça joue aussi dans la tête c'est parti
il fait peur Magnus mais tu l'as déjà
battu dans le premier match tu peux
encore le faire une deuxième fois al
resa j'ai quasiment envie de dire àz
resa bah il hésite il hésite entre
cavalier pr et tour F1 là c'est sûr ah
faut pas trop hésiter là il a plus que 3
minutes il va falloir prendre une
décision jouer un
coup il joue
B4 pourquoi il joue
B4 ah parce qu'il veut P on prend 4
cavalier C6 tour B6 B5 OK et il veut
tour B6 tour F1
ou cavalier C4 ou les
deux alors là l'ordi aime pas à cause de
tour bd8
ok tour bd8 je vais te bouffer ton pion
quand
même je comprends en fait où est ton
problème je te prends ton pion en fait
ouais non on va pas s'occuper de ce que
dit Lordi je pense qu'il raconte nimp
ok d raconte
nimp il raconte pas nimp du tout en fait
mais on va se dire que c'est il va pas
trouver non il va pas
trouver il peut l'avoir par pure chance
en fait ça m'énerve ah il l'a par pure
chance mais après c'est Pascal prend pas
le pion direct qu' doit prendre6 tour D2
et en fait le fou F2 est hyper bien
placé pour pour tout
défendre
ah c'est terrible
OK prend C6 il va ramener la tour en D2
il la met en D6 mais B5 F prend E4 et en
en réalité on a un problème c'est que le
fou défend bien les cases noires bah
c'est vraiment pas de bol quand même bon
faut faire à
je crois il y a un problème débile de
mat sur la première rangée aussi genre
un truc comme si on fait A5 E3 A6 E2
disons roage 2 ah il commence à faire
tour des TR fou prend et il vient sur la
première rangée en fait
ouais on arrive pas on n arrive pas à
passer on est dans un réseau de
math ah c'est
qata ouais cavalier prend C direct en
fait ça laissait pas du tout ces
opportunités là l'adversaire oh là là là
là
là ah là là là là là là c'est
terrible ah c'est terrible ah c'est
terrible c'est terrible il a pas senti
la force de cette tour qui arrivit là
avec ce fou qui va défendre
il fait tour B4 c'est très bien joué
tour B4 il veut E3 tour prend G4 et tour
E4 et s'enlever des réseaux de math ah
c'est excellemment bien joué alors
peut-être on y recroit tour B4 c'est un
super coup là qui vient nous sortir
àira il s'enlève de ses réseaux
là-bas et il va récup le pion g toujours
important allez on prend G4 bam là faut
le manger le pion quand même non il
hésite pourquoi il
hésite pourquoi il hésite à aller
prendre un pion en fait ce pion il nous
met dans des réseaux il nous pose des
problèmes depuis tout à l'heure bam on
le prend sur échec on revient en E4
pourquoi pourquoi il tankque maintenant
oh non il fait ça spécial là
alirea je crois qu'il a peur de tour des
deux deux mais tu as pas le choix de
toute façon il fait pourquoi il fait
tour qu
direct qu'est-ce que c'est que
ça
ah il veut tour D4 cavalier D4 tour D2
cavalier D4 il
veut ah mais c'est juste nul il y a puis
on prend t prend8 3 F7 et D3
c'est juste naz en
fait
ouais c'est juste de et tour
des après il était pas bien de partout
le fait d'avoir laissé la tour revenir
c'était vraiment mal joué il aurait dû
faire juste tour F1 tour F5 si
paniquer mais là ça va en être terminé
minus Carlsen qui va doucher nos espoirs
plus rien ne marche Magnus
facile
il fait tour
F1 mais bon
[Musique]
là je crois que tout marche va être la
même sans le pion G4 c'est quand même
pas tout à fait pareil
ouais ça a très bien joué pendant
longtemps et ça a fini par
imploser
ouais pas laisser le RO venir en F7 mais
au final le fait que le roi soit pas avu
en
F7 ça pose plus de problème qu'autre
chose F7 en fait était juste moins bien
placé qu'en G8 en
plus il va abandonner il tombe
autant c'est rid B après le le moment
était
passé
pr G4 3 F7 tour E4 tour D2
ouais il pouvait faire tour F1 ici en
fait cétait pas du tout la même il
pouvait faire exactement la même idée
mais
ouais mais en ayant bouffé le pion G4
c'est la même position mais avec le roi
noir moins bien placé un pion de plus
pour les blancs
ouais Magnus scène qui s'impose qui
mérite sa victoire hein il a il a été il
a été plus fort aujourd'hui je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi ce ce live
c'était c'était très très très très cool
euh c'était un beau match alira qui a
bien commencé qui a mis la tête sousot à
Magnus mais Magnus finalement qui bah
ouais qui est fort et qui réussit malgré
tout à reprendre le dessus et à
l'emporter je vous remercie encore
d'avoir suivi le match je vous remets le
petit lien comme vous m'avez demandé
plusieurs fois dans le chat pour le pour
le stage avec Fab au passage
et et je vous dis et je vous dis à
après-demain pour le championnat 960 où
il y aura de nouveau alier Rea firouja
et Magnus Carlsen notamment il y aura
aussi Ding liren et beaucoup d'autres
bonne fin de soirée et à bientôt ciao
ciao le de
évén
exorur
et
하